[Musique]
cela fait 27 ans que de bloc québécois
fait partie du paysage
c'est beaucoup trop du propre aveu de
son fondateur lucien bouchard dans mon
esprit à l'époque je voyais pas le bloc
s'installer à perpétuité à ottawa le
voici sur la scène à sorel-tracy avec
déjà louis plamondon à ses côtés gilles
duceppe et jean lapierre le cofondateur
et l'objectif est très clair
son succès sera mesurée à la brièveté
son existence radio canada prévoit que
l'opposition officielle au prochain
parlement sera formée par le bloc
québécois
les premières années du parti l'appui
est très seul aux élections de 1993 le
bloc rafle 54 sièges après le référendum
perdu
lucien bouchard fait ses adieux à ottawa
ça nous fait de la peine de le voir
partir
gilles duceppe reprend le flambeau mais
des questions se posent sur l'existence
du bloc belle offre peut-être pour
jackass yala personnage dans sa partie
et le déclin commence avec un premier
creux aux élections de 2000 le scandale
des commandites laisse des traces
l'électorat revient vers le bloc quatre
ans plus tard et se maintient en 2008
ce un bloc québécois ce soir stephen
harper formerait un gouvernement mais
l'effondrement se profile et la vague
orange sur laquelle surfe jack layton se
fracasse contre le bloc
le bloc québécois perd son statut de
parti il n'a que quatre élus en 2011
et parmi eux il n'ya même pas gilles
duceppe en conséquence j'annonce que je
quitte mes fonctions
mario beaulieu lui ne fera que passer à
la tête de la formation
c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé à gilles
duceppe d'âgés fléchir à l'idée de
revenir
il revient en sauveur et parvient à
sauver les meubles
ils sont dix députés en 2015 une
nouvelle cheffe et trois ans plus tard
ils sont désormais trois jours si
mathieu prost radio canada